all right i'm gonna give you a straight
up vampire c-section like we was edward
and bella
hold up
you like twilight yeah i like tri light
you like twilight
twilight's my jam
[Music]
though man you are so local man wow
we need a crazy bottle like you in our
game
so with this bandana
i welcome you to the game yo
hold up okay what's going on hey
kalito
i was just
welcoming eduardo into the game
why
who he what he did
he's he's crazy man
we we were thinking that the game is a
crazy guy yeah i mean this guy is locum
eduardo
no no i'm the local one in this game
what okay okay check this out
quack quack
i'm a duck no no no i'm a crazy duck no
carlito solito it's not that kind of
local okay that's more like you know
zany or or goofy yeah it's the wrong
kind of loco you want to see loco lito
you're not crazy
you're like uh
the quiet one i'm not quite
never because being quiet in fact
i'm always loud check it
um
okay okay that was weird yeah how much
were you yelling i'll show you local
right here
right now in broad daylight
your y'all homes i got telecom on my
underwear that's the black fish i'm
naked and i don't even care
you got to pull them up okay there's
like children in this neighborhood okay
okay but check this out i got nine punch
cards from froyo universe each with a
one stamp in it every time i get a froyo
i get a new card callito that's just
being cavalier with your finances
instead of collecting your free dessert
i mean that's not local that's just like
financially irresponsible
i might not be local but you know who is
loco
my friend
mr basoda head
he's dumping the garbage hey i'm the
most local person in here
polito why would you do that okay
okay kalito
you don't have to do this okay it's not
necessary you're not the local
check this out
yeah
i'm crazy i'm the local one oh
golito please don't do it again
stop i'm into d this is like watching
the british version of the office like
it's funny but awkward and sad at the
same time yes
oh well
i think i just proved this bottle is
unbreakable
carlito
you're embarrassing yourself look at
this no it's local no no no carlito what
are you going to do with that i don't
know i'm too crazy
ah kalito why would you do that man that
was local but not in an entertaining way
okay
okay
look at that huh
put the gun down crazy
don't put it down
you just shot eduardo in the head
now i'm the most local in the game
yes carlito by process of elimination
you are the most local person in the
gang
yes
that's the most
okay let's get this thing going
everybody take a seat
we gotta have more meetings homes
because i'm telling you man we gotta get
organized
carlito ain't got a seat man someone
gave him a chair
no i'm cool no dude
get him at your homes
nah man
i'm gonna sit gangster
but kalito it doesn't look like it's
comfortable man why don't you just sit
in the chair
i'm never sitting on a chair essay
you're never ever gonna catch me sitting
in no chairs
like i said you know that that's local
right i don't know
it's cool carlito no one's gonna think
you're soft if you sit in a chair yes
yeah we're all sitting in chairs hey a
bunch of bitch-ass cooleros
okay i don't have no time to sit in a
[ __ ] chair
huh
okay
now that we're all here
you know what but why though like it it
don't make no sense for you to set
yourself up with the rule like that no
it's like
limiting yeah limiting
i mean sometimes people sit in chairs
man [ __ ] all of you guys with your
bitch-ass chair
there
okay kalito quit playing and sit in the
chair pendejo no calito we have to have
this meeting now ese get up
i'm good right here man you know i'm
chilling
go ahead with your meaning okay but you
know it's gonna be weird
you don't care it's gonna be weird weird
for you maybe
he doesn't care okay
okay homies so this is what we have to
do
like we gotta sell more drugs and we
gotta make more crimes happen roberto
where are we
kalito you're bleeding essay
who cares man
oh
yo whoa you just got shamed man we gotta
pull that out leave it
i'm chilling holmes
i don't care about that stupid shank
kalito
golito wake up man
don't even bother essay
i don't need those defibrillator
i don't even want to come back to life
homes golito
go back into your body my body's stupid
humps
i'm fine right here on the spirit plane
life is for [ __ ]
[Music]
man i don't need to go to heaven homes
heaven is for [ __ ] oh boy
[Music]
forget this fool man he's fronting
ain't no one here scared of you you
fake-ass gangster
get your fake ass up out of here
you were scared for like a minute though
this you're eating his gun
[Music]
looking at
[Music]
[Music]
you ready homie hells yeah let's take
these out
hold up
nah
what
we gotta go back home man
why
i pooped my pants
what just now
i just put my pants
you got diarrhea hell no man i ain't gay
we gotta go home right now man let me
change my draw some of the dudes be
trying to smoke is right there man how
you want me to smoke somebody when i got
poop in my pants
are you sure you pooped them am i short
am i short yeah
yes that is poop in my pants nasty man
it's natural man for a three-year-old
not for a hardcore gangster see with my
real friend though you wouldn't make
such a big deal out of it wouldn't make
such a big deal out of it
okay you a grown-ass man who just in his
drawers
oh snap
no you didn't
get you
pants again don't judge you need to get
out of my car and go to the hospital
okay i see how it see
i wouldn't do that to you though you
never would have to do that to me
because under no circumstances whatever
my pants
i'm sorry i judged you apology accepted
what what what wait what check yourself
before i body pierce your damn skull
think you can pull that trigger before i
blow your personality out the back of
your head then go right ahead and test
the hypothesis and see what happens all
right i'm gonna give you a straight up
vampire c-section like we was edward and
bella
hold up
you like twilight yeah i like twilight
you like twilight
twilight's my jam
you were edwin
answer that together three two one
inside my head yo and when you said you
was gonna blow my personality out the
back of my head i'm like
that sounds like something i would say
and now there's twilight
wavelengths so i guess we friends then
are we best friends now we the best of
friends bffs we are bffs mf
[Applause]
the world stops
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no you did
[Laughter]
too much
[Music]
team
dead word
[Music]
well
looks like another gang-related kelly
surprise the mother
prize
godfather thank you for coming
first order of business i'm sure you all
heard the twigs got pulled out the river
this morning there ain't no secret he
and carvel
grew up in the hood together
listen up
carville about to say some words
[Music]
okay you know what don't none of you
look at them tears and think that's just
funny
because it takes a big
man to cry in front of his crew
go ahead come here
y'all know twigs with my boy
back in the day
we used to pretend the sofa cushions was
a fort
and we used to pretend that the floor
was molten lava
okay you know what though
ain't nothing funny about that
of course this man is crying
because he and twigs was kids together
okay
you know there's best friends for evan
go ahead carvel
we used to play care bear
twigs and i would spend
the good part of an afternoon trying to
figure out with carebear
oh
[Music]
i wish one of y'all
would just start laughing cuz you all
know you think this is funny
carmel over here blubbering and talking
about care bears
but you know what
but you
thought some manly tears
okay
there was some manly ass tears right
there that you looking at
go ahead carmel
i'm sorry man that was a weird ass
sneeze i just did right there god damn
it can the brother get some claritin up
in here
go ahead carmel
twigs always fancied himself cher bear
i always
i always thought
thought of myself as more of a fun shine
there okay
okay oh you need to respect that right
there okay
y'all need to listen to fun
i'm sorry i'm sorry man
you were funshine bear man i'm sorry
that that is so funny
[Laughter]
all right let's go sell some crack
hey
y'all for real though
this right here yeah this goes out to
all our fallen homies yo
come on hey yo real tall all right
i mean
it just seems like a waste
right
does that make me a dick
okay i'm a dick okay i'm addicted i'm
sorry
i'm a big old girl
okay here
for our homies
come on man watch your damn beer okay
let's go all right fine
glug glug glug glug glug glug gold come
on
hey man you got your thumb okay okay
okay you need to respect our homies
okay
for the homies
whoa
trash beer what come on hey beer is beer
jeez i cannot win on this one what fine
i'm not on board with this but i'll do
it
hey what you doing oh really that don't
count
oh hey put that that's not oh man
it's more of a symbol than a gesture
somebody back me up on this hey
hey man that's disrespectful right there
you just do it fine fine i'll pour it
out i'll waste the damn beard in
you know
i'm just not a waster you know i save
everything jamal knows if you eat a
piece of pizza and don't eat the crust i
eat the crust if we do a drive-by
shooting i will go back for the shell
cases not to hide the evidence
but because you can recycle those
they have value man just like this beer
i can't waste nothing y'all it's
physically impossible for me to waste
this
i can't do it
jamon
can you pour it out for me
[Music]
no matter what dog
don't snitch i ain't saying nothing dude
you know me i die before i turn snitch
we tell them nothing
they got nothing
you think j-rock talking hell no dog
they rock is my cousin
that man would never snitch all right so
just chill out here
oh hey bring that ice when you get that
chance dwight all right man
you're the man knight
[ __ ] ass cot what up j rock they hurt
you up in there she may hurt you look
how he just got back from the snack shop
what you say to them man
[Music]
nothing
this is my man right here all right my
brother
this man ain't never snitch on nobody
never
whatever
now look
we in this together man
nobody said nothing right
right right right right nobody gonna say
nothing about how big girls shot up that
liquor store
no no no
it wasn't big girl what the hell are you
talking about
everyone
hell mom bug shot's the one that held up
that liquor store
buckshot
now where is he going
i don't know maybe he's going to the
bathroom
man he's going in there to snitch on us
let me tell you something that's my boy
right there we grew up together that is
a stand-up g
that man would never snitch pizza's home
pizza time pizza time everybody love
pizza time wake up in the morning it's
pizza time
and eating pizza time pizza pizza pizza
time mother
hold on
now j-rock um
where'd you get the pizza
back there
and your tiny piece of breath ass and
then i'm gonna bury you in my mother's
basement was the rest of the snitches
what
wait wait wait [ __ ] where you going
where you going where you going man we
go oh
[Music]
see look look look he's selling me out
right now no no no he's saying that i
would never sell out that man
what
i'm telling you
all right all right
let's go let's go come on yo man see
what i tell you rockwell huh what'd i
tell you you ass snitch-ass
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay you know what it wasn't my fault
all right
i i i had the money like you said in a
trash bag in the back of my car and i
was gonna go straight to the drop spot
all right
no no oh okay okay okay okay no
hey hey hey hey man there ain't no need
for you to get comfortable okay because
because i i'm telling you man what
happened wasn't my fault all right i i i
i i i drove to the agreed upon location
man oh come on
come on
okay okay okay okay
okay because there's no need to have
anything crazy in a paper bag i'm
telling you there's an explanation for
what went down
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay let's calm down
now
let's calm down man there ain't no need
oh not a juice box
there ain't no need to eat a meal and
then do some crazy
with a sandwich container and a juice
box
oh man come on
come on man
just chill out a little bit just do you
need to relax man you need to take it
easy and relax oh
oh god damn now come on man don't do it
don't do it don't don't man you come on
man oh eating the sandwich you eat the
sandwich
oh man how you gonna sandwich me dog how
you gonna sandwich me oh
okay look it's getting crazy now it's
gonna stop it's gotta stop right now
okay you cleaning yourself up before you
do some ill come on man what you doing
what you wanna know but i'll tell you
whatever you want to know man just
please stop this cold ass man i'm
thanking you dawg please oh
no no okay let's okay man maybe it was
my fault a little bit maybe it's my
fault a little bit but don't just what
you want to do with that juice box man
we're going to do a dutch we're don't
know what's strong
what are you gonna do with this job
come on man dude listen listen no no no
i did it i did i did it okay i did it i
did i left the car i left for three
minutes so please don't do anything with
the straw why aren't you stopping
okay
i got your point all right man
huh
oh
man that's a [ __ ]
[Music]
will we be having any more problems out
of him sir
no
yeah
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]